all right so I'm a Lumas my name is
nobody can really pronounce my name so I
put it up there for you yeah you're
based originally from Israel and I've
been a I'm obsessed about data
infrastructure for the past 15 years or
so I'm now a Loomis founder and CEO and
trying to help people that are obsessing
about their data infrastructure before
that and this is actually what I'm the
story that I'm going to tell today is my
story at contract media which is an
advertising technology company in which
we have built a lot of data
infrastructure this is going to be
repeating concept and I spent 12 years
in the military before that also
building a lot of data infrastructure
and I am like I said excited to be here
so in in convert media we were in
advertising Tony company does any of you
here work at attack by a quick show of
hands yeah so you should know there is a
lot of data there we started really
building an ad server which is a started
as a very very simple thing let's just
have a server that every time a user
wants to see an ad or something want to
show the user and ad to be more accurate
they would get the server would get a
request to show which ad to show and
then we just spit it back out and would
count what what it displayed in this my
sequel database and this is how it
started and then the business grew a
little bit so every time the server was
down we were losing money so we had to
start enabling notifications on top for
logs so we had all of our events going
to a log and then some workers that were
firing notification if we should get up
in two in the morning and do something
about the business losing money and then
we wanted to start doing some fancy data
science stuff so we put all the data in
Hadoop and then also in data in HP
vertica at that time so like OLAP
database and then started drawing all
kinds of machine learning on top of it
to be able to display smarter ads
and then eventually we also needed more
metrics and more dashboards so the data
was going also into a time series
database and a caching layer because the
volume became too big and over time this
became a really really complex system so
essentially every event that comes in
was duplicated to all these places and
then our the in the industry have
changed a little bit and real-time
bidding whether hinder real-time bidding
was introduced which essentially people
said instead of repaying for all of this
empty space we want to choose in real
time do we want to display an ad and how
much we want to pay for it so
essentially what happened is every time
there is an opportunity to display at
the padukas is coming out and there is
Google as an exchange and Microsoft were
investing of exchange and Yahoo had an
extensive there were all of the big
companies were in this game they would
give all of the bidders the opportunity
to say how much are they going to pay
now to explain it right now to a
specific user in a specific URL and our
job was to give a price back essentially
what we said okay we build a really
really fancy machine learning unheard-of
cluster that would predict how much we
are willing to pay for an ad so let's
put it into action so it started with
the key value store just to get a data
on the user and on the and on the URL
that were currently going into and we
had like a billion keys there and we had
to return a response about 20
milliseconds so which was a lot to 300
million in the US which is basically the
u.s. I'll take it everywhere and as you
can guess it got complicated similar to
the ad server because also notification
and monitoring and then batchi deal and
what made things even worse is that
these things had to talk to each other
as well so suddenly the bidder needs to
speak to the ad server database to
understand how much money was spent on
the campaign and it can it now bid or
the ad server would need to ask the
video some things and then the models
were pushed from one
I do plaster to the other and it became
homeless and as you can guess this
really really really cannot scale and
you I'm guessing that at least some of
you are in that spot today so one one
reason it cannot scale is discrepancy so
every trend is multiplied into many
different things and they could never
agree with each other so if I stick to
the to the campaign budget so
essentially every campaign at the budget
and you can spend this amount of money
per day if you spend more money nobody's
gonna pay you for that money so you
don't want to overspend because it's
money going out of your pocket but it's
really hard to overspend and to make
things even worse the customers are
looking fun - were that's coming from
one database the application look it's
another thing building goes from the
application and then you get very angry
customers asking you why they pay why we
want them to pay not what was actually
explained and then as well so no two
systems here was ever willing to agree
with each other and we were really
struggling - and said okay what is
really data and this is wrong
recovered from failures is really hard
as well because the state is being story
in database I'm not sure if any of you
have ever used my I some table to store
a state they probably encounter this
error if they haven't they should tank
thank their lucky stars but the the
point is that if the state is lost it's
really hard to recover it and not only
it's hard to recover it but the
application keeps running when they
staged class so going back to my
campaign story five minutes of no state
can actually just ruin the entire margin
for the entire day because we were just
spending money that is not accounted for
and we would still need to pay this
money and then what happens is that
solutions like and this is the real
solution people are creating a slave
that has an artificial a lot built in so
if you have a disaster you're really
quickly hot swapping to the slave that
has dragged where the disaster didn't
happen yet and again this is wrong if
you're doing that and I was doing that
for a long time
and then I think we replaced every key
component of our system at some point so
it feels a little bit like a heart
transplant
while everything need to be connected
while you pull one piece out and then
try to put the other piece in and then
really quickly take all the pipes and
connect them to the other piece and and
then if you have and then of course all
of the applications that are talking to
this new infrastructure let's say you
want to replace my sequel for prosperous
still needs to be functioning and keep
talking to each other so you need to
deploy all of the code in the same time
if you have a bug and you need to revert
then you're really in a bad state so
replacing a key component is really
really difficult when in this type of
infrastructure and this is another thing
that we have spent a lot of time doing
because for example for the key value
store using Voldemort which was an
open-source project a while ago then we
replaced to MongoDB then we placed our
spike every time when the scale grows we
need some other tool so eventually
that's what's going on when your
business grows and you have more
application that multiplication is
modifications and then some more and
then they talk to each other
and then maybe you even have more and
I'm sure some of you know this states
very intimately and I've been talking to
her - pretty much
I don't know 200 big companies in the
past year and many many of them are at
this position and what I'm thinking is
that there has to be a better way and
and I think it's important to say I
don't think that I'm going to say
anything new here so I apologize up
front I think it's all been said but I
think still it's not being practiced so
people are not taking the smart thing
that people have been saying over the
years and merging them into let's build
a framework and that's built it that way
so that we can really stop obsessing
about all this and the industry have
changed and the tools that we have
available to us now have also changed so
we can do it better and we should so
this is the path to sanity and I'll try
to go over it like one one by one so
number one is never duplicate events and
do an event sourcing instead of state
source and this is a very simple concept
it's also a very old concept but it's
somewhat hard to implement essentially
instead of doing the create update we
delete normal database interaction just
treat everything as an immutable set of
events and everything that happened in
the world is an event and then put
everything in an immutable event log
instead of trying to update five
different databases with the same event
where two of them fail and then you
don't know what to do and this has more
advantages over just not duplicating
events for example and also remember
that the database table is essentially
in the front lock I mean if you look at
any database what it has is an event log
the table is just syntactic sugar /
beautiful presentation of this event log
but under hood it's really the event log
so why let the database do the
abstraction for you if you can just do
it yourself and then let's say consider
the difference between saying this
campaign have spent $10 so add $10 so to
spend over saying
set the total spend to 110 dollars
because the first one can be reverted
the second one cannot and let's say and
there is a big big problem of bought and
fraud in the ad tech industry let's say
you need to cancel an event because it
was a fraud if you did a set you have no
way to do that but if you did just
append only you can just discard it and
then recompute the state so whenever you
have L you have an event log you can
reprocess the state and this is useful
also for events coming out of order
which is also a very common problem with
a synchronous mentioning systems
especially with sometimes difficult
connectivity from many many many
different clients and it is very very
useful in case of failures because again
the state the material is view of the
state or the representation at a table
for example can be recalculated again
and again and again from there from the
source data away then if it's heavy
processing you can always if you have it
processing you can always just save
intermediate state but you can always
recalculate everything from beginning
while having this event so the past of
sanity number one is using event log and
materialized views for this event log
every time the number two is take
essentially get rid of this so this is
there was a very famous paper called
beating the cap theorem by Nathan Mars
that was displaying this lambda
architecture I'm sure some of you heard
of it
unfortunately cap theorem still stands
if you're wondering and still holds true
but the idea was we have some things
that we want to parse in real time and
some things run to pass in batch let's
make a speed table and batch table have
the applications variables so that we
can so that we can always have the data
that we need in real time in real time
and what takes a long time to process we
can process later the problem so what I
like about this approach is it keeps its
holding true to the event log so every
change in immutable states and all of
the benefits that we've got
that's great however it means you need
to maintain your code in two different
places that does two different thing you
need to maintain two different
distributed architecture so let's say
you do the batch on Hadoop and the
real-time on
spark stream and it means that you need
your code in two different places and it
needs to and you also need to maintain
two different very very complicated
systems now the underlying reason was
that people thought that the streaming
things are not capable enough to handle
large volume of events and also that the
guarantee the semantics guarantees were
not good enough so I think I've heard
someone saying hopefully once yesterday
in hopefully ones processing of events
which is probably what most people do
but we have a lot of good stream
processing framework today and they can
deliver probably the same guarantee that
you can get from batch and it can
probably be fast enough and you if you
are still doubting this just think of
uber surge pricing calculation they need
in real time to know where all of the
drivers are where all of the cars are
and get out of price in real time and
they Pro and they do it over their
streaming infrastructures so I assume
that not many people here have such a
big stream friends coming in and then
the streaming architecture that we have
today are probably good enough so
essentially get rid of this and just do
the real-time processing and and this is
also not new this was they stopped
working
it was mentioned by Jake reps about two
or three years ago already all right I
got it then the third path to sanity and
I think this is the most important piece
if to abstract the data layer and 15
years ago when we wanted to start a
software company the first thing we had
to take care of is a server room and
power and cooling and we had to worry
about how much fun we have in the server
in fact when I was in the military
our biggest problem with every project
we did whether the server room did not
have enough power every time we try to
put our server there anyway because they
needed it the power would fail and then
the generator would kick in and then
people would get tested but today our
lives are so much easier we only need to
think about our application patterns how
much memory we need how much CPU we need
how much storage we need and just
provision it magically on the cloud we
don't care how Amazon does their cooling
in server room we don't care which how
Hardware our server is running on we
just don't care and this is just saving
so much time and money and enabling us
to start building stuff so much faster
and then the next day of abstraction was
the application server layer so we don't
even deploy our application anymore we
just put them in containers and push
them to the cloud and it's so easy so in
Illuma for example if a developer want
to showcase a feature branch they just
push the docker to the cloud and then
everyone can look at it and no need to
deploy anything anymore but every time
we think about data it backwards it is
backwards so we are thinking about our
data infrastructure instead of a data
access pattern we are still thinking in
terms of the power and cooling of data
when thinking do I need to use Cassandra
20 to use MongoDB do I need to use HDFS
or hive or whatever this is the power
and cooling what we really do think is
what is my data access pattern do I need
a 20 millisecond response time over key
value store do I need
do I need to run a very big query over a
year of data but it can run in 30 second
because it's for some kind of a report
unfortunately we still don't have the
way to do that so this is the idea is to
move to an API layer and have an API
layer so from here where we have all
these different applications and every
application is essentially talking to
all these databases to here so we have
our applications they are pushing all of
the events into the event log that we
have discussed on the event logs there
are materialized views but they are
being material ID also to an API layer
that obstructs the infrastructure itself
but only talks in terms of requirements
so for example I need a 20 millisecond
response time and then the API will know
ok I need to put it in a key value store
so I'm going to need to run a MapReduce
type of job and then I can push it into
a do but again the point is they the
application should not care
what's implementing this key value store
it should just be provision
automatically according to the volume
according correspond time according to
what - whatever you may need
and then when building application that
way a lot of the issues that we're
experiencing can be alleviated pretty
easily so failure recovery is pretty
easy because we can recalculate the
state and discrepancy is virtually
non-existent because there is only one
sort of truth now there is one caveat to
that that some services that we use are
not working that way so let's say we use
some fast provider for one of our
applications let's say we salesforce and
we store off a sales data and cell for
cell phones is a transactional database
it is not talking in events but then we
can build actually a gateway layer for
animating that will already told in 2005
we can build a gateway layer for all
these services it will either use web
hooks to post every event and some of
them do or just pull it every
such-and-such time and pull the change
as an event this is a little bit clunky
but it's the best you can get and this
also lets you go back in time and then
so imagine we have all of our cloud
services over here and then another
layer
of connectors to be the gateways for
these services and that way even
external things that happen in
application which are out of our control
completely are also adhering to the
scheme of putting everything in the
event log and only display materialized
views so these are the layer of
abstractions that that eventually I have
in mind and we discussed the event log
we have a lot of and Casca I think is
becoming de-facto a solution for the
event log I think more and more people
are just using that as the event log
bottom layers are still more diverse but
I think maybe the biggest ones probably
a storm spark streaming and Sam's
probably covering most of the most of
the use cases but we are getting better
posting rails and copper streams of
course with better guarantees and then
we can build some common services so
things like schema depository there is
no need for every application to build
some schema repository we can build a
schema repository service that sit on
the event log and store the schema or
for example notification link every
application builds its own education if
we just had a service to tender
notifications all the applications can
just talk to the service so some build
some common service and then connectors
were the views of being materialized on
the different places where the data
needs to be processed now it is still
okay to do some post posting in batch it
- so for example if we do want to run
some job that will take you very long
time it's okay to put it to do it in
batch crossing way just let's not do it
twice if we need to do it twice once on
the stream and then once in batch then
we were doing something wrong so if I
want to recap the three main things that
the way I think we should we should
build our applications who they are
let's prefer event sourcing over state
databases and let's just do a penalty
the updates and no deletes and no just
just append and then merge the real time
in the batch infrastructure into the
real time infrastructure because we have
good enough to do that today and at the
time has come to abstract in Italy
now this this talk is not about Illuma
but I do want to mention that this is
what we're trying to build this is why I
founded Aloma I'll be happy to talk
about it later with anyone that is
interested thank you if you have
questions just raise your hand I'll come
over to you at the microphone so so
again I I prefer to talk about the
general live-streaming fly modes
this will hold true to all them as well
our does but essentially the the problem
is just it's just a trade-off of how
much money you're willing to put so
essentially the frameworks do they exist
where they really have a scale out
architecture that you can add more
servers and handle more throughput as
long as you you know you don't have
crazy partition key requirements you can
just add more an you can handle and I've
seen deployment that does anywhere
between you know ten thousand to two
hundred thousand seven per second and
I've heard but not seen with my own eyes
also about million event per second so
the frameworks doesn't really have this
limitation yeah well so what you're
building sounds like it kind of removes
a lot of the interdependence between
data scientists and data engineers do
you see data scientist as potentially
working a lot more autonomously within
this kind of environment yeah and this
is actually I really like this question
because what we've seen but I've seen in
many of the people after data of
scientists I've been talking to if they
are getting really frustrated especially
in bigger companies where engineering is
really separated completely from them so
they have to beg to IT resources to get
some data so yeah for sure part of the
thing is to set the data scientist free
and and again if I quoted the I quoted
I'm dressed called the beginning of this
talk so the headline of the article was
Madison Avenue please set my data
scientist free so I really believe in
that
yeah
with multiple people materializing the
event log in multiple different ways how
do you keep track of all the different
materializations and figure out what it
is that you've materialized so the
question was what should we use the
material with all the different
infrastructure that are able to ensure
the views that exist today oh yeah
so that is hard but I mean eventually
you can categorize them two different
options to do things and then it once
you categorize them it takes time for
you know a new player to really be much
better at this specific thing that the
existing things and it's hard to keep
track of it I tried but it's better be
done by someone where that's their
business
comparing to having to track on it when
my business was to build a real-time
bidding engine alright thank you